[Music]
three suburban philadelphia police
officers have been charged in the death
of an eight-year-old girl fantability
was shot by police last summer as she
was leaving in high school football game
with her family according to prosecutors
the officers were responding to another
report of gunfire when they fired toward
a crowd there's been a massive public
outcry for her justice in this case and
meg oliver has been following it meg
good morning nate good morning the
officers have been released on bail and
the borough is scheduled to meet
thursday to discuss whether the officers
will keep their jobs the charges against
them follow a grand jury investigation
and a months-long community outcry for
police accountability
this is a
a terrible tragedy that has engulfed our
entire community nearly five months
after the shooting of eight-year-old
fantability three sharon hill police
officers were charged in connection with
the child's death
officers devin smith shawn dolan and
brian devaney were each charged with
voluntary and involuntary manslaughter
and 10 counts of reckless endangerment
when did you determine that the fatal
bullet was from an officer's gun we
initially determined back in i think the
september time frame we're now sure
beyond a reasonable doubt that the
officer
shoot not only killed
fantability but they also wounded three
other young people bility was killed
last summer after two teens exchanged
gunfire at the end of a football game
prosecutors say the three responding
officers saw a vehicle heading toward
them that they mistakenly believe was
involved in the shooting they fired 25
rounds striking the car and four people
in the area they returned fire at the
wrong target in the wrong direction and
into a group of people
that's what they're being held
accountable for initially the two teens
who opened fire at each other were the
only ones charged with murder in
connection with her death
that decision drew protests and an
outcry for the officers to be held
accountable now the district attorney is
withdrawing the charges against the
teens attorney bruce castor represents
the ability family fonta was the most
adorable little girl you ever would see
i mean to have her go on is just a
terrible terrible tragedy
fanta would have turned nine last
saturday we reached out to attorneys
representing the officers and did not
hear back but in a joint statement the
legal team maintained their client's
innocence stating they rushed to the
sound of gunshots and risked their own
lives to protect the community the
officers are due back in court for a
preliminary hearing on january 27th it's
a very hard situation
the officers are trying to do the right
thing and it's a tough situation for
sure uh and and they're there because
somebody else file fired uh their gun
off um yeah but at the end of the day an
eight-year-old girl is dead yeah it's
true someone's gonna be held accountable
the attorney some did it very well wrong
target fired at the wrong target in the
wrong direction yeah but it is a very
hectic situation they're trying to
figure out exactly what's going on yeah
it was interesting here that the charges
were dropped against the two teens the
murder charges but they should still
face some charges right they still face
some charges and they they were in one
of the teenagers was in court yesterday
and pleaded guilty to those there's
reckless endangerment however those
other charges were dropped and there is
controversy over that is isn't there a
bigger story when it comes to
the recklessness of exchanging fire in
public especially at a high school game
in a crowd 25 shots by the officers
five shots by the teenagers
30 shots in a crowd i mean someone's got
to be accountable meg thank you very
much